1960 année d'élection présidentielle aux
états unis pour la première fois la
télévision s'immisce dans la campagne
électorale
le 26 septembre les deux candidats à
l'élection s'affrontent sur le petit
écran
d'un côté richard nixon vice président
des états unis télé ritchen l'ex
candidat républicain 47 ans marié deux
enfants de l'autre john fitzgerald
kennedy candidat démocrate sénateur du
massachusetts est peu connu du grand
public où les catholiques ce qui lui
vaut la méfiance d'un certain nombre
d'américains
il a épousé une très jolie femme ce qui
est un atout aux états unis enfin et
surtout son père est un homme très riche
et très puissant le débat télévisé a
lieu dans les locaux de la chaîne cbs
très vite
kennedy se démarquent plus à l'aise et
reposait que son adversaire fatigué et
amaigri le costume gris de nixon se
confondent même avec le décor pour
georges galope le précurseur des
sondages d'opinion aux états unis
kennedy a remporté la bataille de
l'image
c'est la première fois qu avait lieu
c'est juste aurait poids télévisés et
tout le monde s'accorde à dire que les
syriennes et des ja t'es le meilleur
les sélections lui et a perdu de
prestige et dévoile grâce à ce débat
john fitzgerald kennedy grappy des voix
dans les sondages canadienne soutient
dinan avait cette fois ci que 43 au
centre et voir au même stade de la
campagne ou patinoire en 1956 avait 57 %
mais d'après les plus récents sondages
il apparaît que les chances tenait sur
unix ans ne cesse de baisser
trois autres débats télévisés suivront 8
novembre 1960 les américains se rendent
aux urnes
kennedy vote à boston nixon a witcher
près de los angeles
au total près de 70 millions d'électeurs
se déplace comme ici à new york
qu'est ce que vous attendez d'un nouveau
président hu a franchement j'attends
quelque chose de mieux que chez lancia
pourquoi l'ancien vous n'avez plus haut
nous avons besoin d'un peuple d'action
ce nouveau président c'est john
fitzgerald kennedy le 9 novembre 1960 il
était lui d'une courte tête c'était pour
kennedy et le parti démocrate en marge
du pouvoir depuis deux législatures la
victoire et le 35e et lui 43 ans fortune
et dynamique entre aujourd'hui dans
l'histoire des états unis
deux nouveaux candidats en 68 et 72 du
char nixon refuse le débat télévisé il
faut attendre 1976 pour que deux
candidats s'affrontent de nouveau à la
télévision
d'un côté le républicain gerald ford de
l'autre le démocrate jimmy carter et
comme en 1960 le débat tourne à
l'avantagé du candidat démocrate
[Musique]